hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm me and
Utah ski the Inga Tashi stand-up comic
friend of mine writer talked about a
movie that everyone unanimously hates
Deadpool now I'm doing something that
might annoy the hell out of you guys but
I kind of like listening to music when I
talk with people so I thought this would
be like kind of cool if I had some
royalty-free music really relaxing
alright for starters one of the best
things about this movie probably the
best thing about this movie and this was
the one thing I was hoping I'd walk away
from most Ryan Reynolds [ __ ] kills it
even if you don't really like the movie
you can't disagree that Ryan Reynolds
nails this [ __ ] role there are
certain guys that are like they're the
only person that can play that character
yeah like Jim Carrey can only play the
Grinch you know what I'm saying there's
nobody else that can play that role yeah
Ryan Reynolds is the only actor alive
that can play Deadpool yeah honestly if
you think about it cuz I thought it
really resembled when he was in Blade 3
yeah who's Hannibal you know and you
just like even then like as soon as a
mountain was dead for Mike I thought of
that instantly I'm like what yeah that's
perfect
you see what's what's so cool about this
I love how it's [ __ ] music skill yeah
that's a good idea in a day and age of
comic book movies there's two things I
noticed one that everyone's talking
about is that it's an r-rated Marvel
movie now I know we've got him blade I
know we've gotten The Punisher but this
is the first one where it's like a
character that's part of a bigger
universe for sure this is part of the
x-men universe and they make that very
clear in this film that it's a part of
the x-men world to see that they took a
spin-off character from a movie that no
one really liked it made it work is so
cool because x-men origins he's only in
it for
when he's actually wait Wilson it's
probably got 15 minutes of screen time I
just watched it again
what's so unique is that normally a
studio would be like that's your one
shot movie sucks sorry we're gonna
recast you for the reboot they instead
said we're gonna reboot this and we're
gonna bring you back you know like I
know Ryan Reynolds really fought for it
and damn that he like owned this role it
was amazing cuz he's always been great
comedic Lee and everything you've ever
seen him in yeah like he always knocks
out of a park and you mix that in with
action sequences yeah and it gives you
something that I've never really
experienced in in like action sequences
or any superhero movie the comedies
always after the fight yeah this you're
getting you're getting all the great
jokes in the middle of these fights yeah
and that's mind blowing and I think
that's why everybody's a jerk in this
movie yeah cuz I heard someone say that
it's one of the best comedies they'd
seen in a long time can't remember who I
don't say it's one of the best comedies
but it's definitely one of the most fun
movies I've seen of all time it is pure
fun that's like the definition of it
like it's rare when you're watching a
movie where grotesque things are going
on and you're like it's actually funny
yeah and then he backs it up with like a
punch line or something you know my
concern was I read some of the comic and
then I was like how can they make this
guy relatable and the movie did a
brilliant job of the first half of it
cuts back between the present and in the
past the present in the past and I
thought like man if they just put the
past in chronological order and in the
beginning it wouldn't have set the mood
and tone for the movie at all and then
if it hopped in the Deadpool world it
would have seen like what were this
[ __ ] come from you know so it was
smart just to tell this origin tale of
Deadpool but tell it in a different kind
of order and I'll allow the movie to
open up just high-impact yeah which is
what you need from a Deadpool movie
right yeah so because a lot of those
when you do those first whatever they're
introducing a new character in the
movies it's always like you've got so
much kind of
to kind of sit through the crap to get
to the part you know yeah it's alright
totally did you have to like go through
the story and all this this movie found
a way to get around this and it was
amazing again you never really felt born
at any moment the movie what I was what
I [ __ ] love about it is it's a
complete film yeah you don't need a
sequel technically you don't yeah you
really did I guess it's the whole story
is done so many of these comic book
movies another note like well I guess we
gotta watch the sequel this movie told a
complete story where it doesn't need a
sequel yet I'm amped for the sequel you
know like that's rare feelings to have
especially with comic book movies
nowadays so the bard is on this movie is
gonna be sent hi yeah so for the sequel
to come out like it's gonna have to set
a pretty you know it's gonna have to
tell you because you're not gonna get
better you have to try to duplicate yeah
it's like it kind of reminds me of the
experience we have with Batman Begins
than the Dark Knight like Batman Begins
came out everyone was like [ __ ]
brilliant when the Dark Knight comes out
of it you're like whoa so so I'm hoping
Deadpool to has that kind of vibe to
because of those past scenes we got we
did get a chance that made sense and
didn't yank me out of the film in it's
serious moments because that was one
thing to when I was doing the comic I'm
like there's never a [ __ ] serious
moment like at least I haven't come
across one the vibe of it is primarily
wacky and goofy and he breaks the fourth
wall all the things you love about
Deadpool but the movie did a great job
of taking the right time to have it be
serious that is what I really credit it
for because that could have been
overdone but they did it just the right
amount because they knew the Wayne
Wilson character so even when the movie
was serious Wade Wilson was still being
his funny self it didn't go too serious
ever yeah
even go further when you say they broke
a foot you did broke the course all
constantly and I want to give it away
but I think it breaks like this fifth
wall
totally they've haven't yeah you got it
when you see it you'll understand I'm
saying but you it's it's amazing
they just keep it it just keeps going
more more meta as it just keeps going
you know and it's just you have to see
them the theater man hell yeah it's a
toll theater it's a theater experience
man just that opening sequence and I
mean I'll tell you this it's only a
handful I'd say less than like three
movies that I've ever seen more than
once in the theater this isn't this is a
movie I go back and see in a heartbeat
totally I'd loved it every every much as
this is the first time and even though
he does own this movie there are good
actors in it that because of the open I
don't want to give away the opening
credits but it does kind of make you
think like are they just gonna make fun
of cliches the whole time yeah but over
they weren't like the characters were
unique TJ Miller
some people might walk away going yeah
he's just doing his TJ Miller thing if
you pay attention like his performance
in Silicon Valley for example versus the
character here you get a much more
sincere version of TJ Miller a more
caring version of TJ Miller
not a narcissistic douchebag you know
like he has his moments where he's being
right here yeah he's wrong here but he's
a different character and I like the
subtle differences of this TJ he doesn't
have an immediately repulsive look about
him either but I will say this cuz TJ
Miller is kind of a unique character
know himself when people say oh he's -
TJ Miller sometimes I'm like that's what
I want to see everything yeah you know
because if you're that good at something
like a Will Ferrell we're like I want to
see Will Ferrell in this Will Ferrell
movie you know but it was cool to see
you I think TJ's like yeah but he did he
didn't play something different but TJ
said just so great he always knocks out
of the park every movie he's done
he knows comedy timing really well and
this movie too had a theme that I was
like no wonder this [ __ ] came out on
Valentine's Day
it's [ __ ] romantic it's romantic like
I'm watching it and I'm like this is not
a typical romantic movie at all but it's
[ __ ] romantic thank you most
beautifully twisted tale of romance
romance you ever seen just like you you
get the connection
you get everything about these two very
flawed character it's cuz the girl who
the girl plays Vanessa is like Marana of
eyebrows really but she plays he plays
minuted schwarzenegger so she plays a
Vanessa his love interest his girlfriend
what I love about the supporting
characters is none of them ever tried to
outshine they all seem like they were in
the same movie you know like this could
have easily been one of those movies
where you're like well you're kind of
out of a different film this one like
she did a great job at playing it very
straightforward at the same time though
there was a level of depth of her just
from her opening scene that makes her
immediately different and interesting
than your typical female character in
one of these films yes you know both of
their backstories you wouldn't think you
do it for either but together you you
want them to succeed and there's the
airport scene interesting
the British bad guy I thought he was
great yeah man I was like I really do
want this guy who died yeah and I think
when a villain does that to you that's a
great feeling because that shows he did
a good job at playing the bad guy cuz as
it is he kept going to Michael they got
a full character here it's not some
cliche villain like this guy's
incredibly smart and he's also very
strong and athletic and stuff and he has
agility it was really cool to see like
huh this is actually one of the best
villains I've seen out of the marble
movies I know it's not part of the MCU
but still that's Stan Lee cameo by the
way yeah and the number two behind the
villain there's a great battle scene
there yeah that is
blowing it you wouldn't think would it
happen like that and it's tie-ins to
because you see in the trailer is gonna
be tie-in to the x-men world and I don't
want to give anything away but the
tie-ins are great Colossus never been
more fun the girl
negasonic teenage warhead she was really
cool she's cool man
ah and and they have a great explanation
as to why they're the only two featured
in the movie there's so many layers of
jokes through like you know just through
the storyline and then through that sub
like you know then yeah like ripping on
itself and then it goes to a different
level and rips on everything inside of
it just like as a comic and as a writer
when I see that I'm just like I'm
completely blown away because like to
hold that script together I know it's in
so it's a comic book movie but I mean
honestly yeah I gotta say it like as far
as fun comic book movies go I think of
movies like wanted kick-ass Kingsman
those are great those are really fun
graphic novel adaptations this is a
character they're setting up to have its
own franchise and hands down out of the
x-men universe out of all the Marvel
films of all that any comic book movie
I've ever seen this is the most fun I've
ever seen a comic book movie have I
gotta say it's one of the best comedic
leads I've ever seen yeah like Ryan
Reynolds kills it even even at times you
don't know if he's under the suit or not
because it could be a stunt double still
the voice work it's delivery it's all
there it's yeah and that's what and
here's the thing we talked about
franchise I wonder if you could ever cuz
he's gonna be insanely popular series
can you ever try to reboot this and I
think the answer's no now
okay so anybody that it's like doing a
the masks - yeah and you're just like
well I think I can do it Jim Carrey does
ya know and fill miserably I think the
same thing will happen just because like
I said Ryan Reynolds is meant to play
that he was born to play that role man
you can see his personality and a lot of
stuff if you've watched all of his
comedies there
you know is the way his style of copy
matches very well with Deadpool sense of
humor and he brings the drama to it he
always brings the brain
three-dimensional performances to comedy
roles and I love this he's a great actor
he's a great eye he's a great actor he
is he knows how to poke fun of itself -
yes which is amazing well guys I know
you can't understand a youtube review
without a rating I don't know why it's
pretty evident how we feel I give it
100% I give it three hundred roubles the
points don't matter why is it yeah yes
whatever the marking system is I get fat
awesome tacular yes - thumbs up four out
of five Smosh eight plus anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the review I
will be doing a spoiler review so keep a
lookout for that not sure who I'm gonna
have with me but keep a lookout for that
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become a reject
and Ian Gutowski has his own channel you
got to check it out he's got a great web
series on there called Satan's corner I
showed it to Tyrone Magnus every video
he watches he just cracks up like so
[ __ ] much so check it out it's a
great it's a great channel and follow me
on Instagram and Twitter vine good stuff
yeah this is like the most serious I've
gotten about promoting myself right now
that's good you did a great job kind of
lüt took command of it you see because I
always feel like when a youtuber is like
talking about subscribe promote it's
always like man they're really trying to
get everything in there to get them
was really popular all across the board
and I feel like I've successfully done
that I'd say and if I could give that a
grade whatever the mark is the highest
mark I would give you that a thousand